As you can see the randomized algorithms generally have much better time bounds
or well they might not seem much, but you already know that for exponential time algorithms
little differences here so 1.47 versus 1.32 actually makes quite a difference
so they have generally a lot better time bounds than the deterministic algorithms
It seems that randomized algorithms allows us to achieve
a better worst-case running time than deterministic algorithms.
Of course, up here it has the advantage that it's actually done after this amount of time
whereas down here, it's always an expected running time
and as I said you're gambling a little bit.
You cannot be 100% sure that the algorithm
has found a satisfying assignment even though there might be one.